- In the last month since "SNL" Jason
has been traveling a lot
and sending us videos,
so let's see a few.
- I'm in my favorite place in London.
I'm coming to you soon.
I can't wait to see you. (smacking lips)
Kelly Clarkson!
Mama, I'm gonna see you soon.
Right now I'm in Shanghai!
Damn it look good.
I'm in Beijing right now,
but it can take me a while.
I got a little bit of a walk,
so I'll see you soon, baby!
(audience laughing and cheering)
(Kelly clapping)
- That was awesome.
I think we're so blessed
because in the entertainment industry,
you get to travel to so many cool places.
What's one of your favorite
places you've been?
- That's pretty amazing
to be on The Great Wall.
- [Kelly] I know, I've
always wanted to do it.
- I've had a couple
opportunities, but that was it.
That was phenomenal
and then I've never been on top
of that building looking at Shanghai.
China was pretty epic.
- Yeah.
- It's been two weeks
we've been traveling,
Brazil, China, I have no
idea where I'm at right now.
- You have no idea...
(audience laughing)
Look, I can tell by your voice-
- The whole time I'm
like, "Kelly Clarkson!"
(audience laughing)
You know why?
(audience applauding)
You're the finish line.
- I'm your last?
- You're the finish line.
- Oh!
- Kelly Clarkson, help me!
- No, I know that promo schedule
'cause I could tell by your
voice when you first spoke,
I was like, "Oh, brother is tired."
(audience laughing)
Yeah, yeah.
You've got that deep thing
that happens when you wake up.
- It's past tired.
I don't even know what it is.
- You know what?
Then it gets fun, it gets silly
and you just start laughing
and crying hysterically
at the same time.
- Yes, yup.
- Well, we'll enjoy this moment.
(audience laughing)
You travel with a guitar and a speaker.
Do you busk everywhere?
What do you do there? (laughing)
- Well, I'm kind of like you.
- Okay, then you must be nuts.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- There's a lot going on-
- Me too.
- So I feel like it just,
it helps me sit still and be quiet.
So it's nice to have
something that just calms me
so the music helps and then,
obviously, playing guitar
just helps my creativity, so I can just-
- [Kelly] No, I'm ADHD, I have to do that.
- Yeah, so guitar just helps me.